leann attempted to make a statement on
society but was yanked after a wave of
online criticism these days more and
more brands are feeling pressure to take
a stand whether it is pulling ads from
controversial media outlets or weighing
in on politics but there is a risk in
doing both they could be alienating some
of their customers for more we're joined
by Jeanine Poggi maybe a reporter for
advertising age good morning morning so
we live in highly a highly charged
political climate is it just inevitable
that brands have to choose which side of
the aisle they want to stand on I don't
think it's inevitable I think that there
are ways to avoid getting involved in
the conversation if you really don't
want to be involved in the political
conversation you obviously don't make a
commercial like Pepsi did but I think
it's become more of a pole for
advertisers to make a stand social media
of course has made it really important
for brands to have a voice and consumers
want to hear what their favorite brands
are saying on topics they care about
I've heard from CEOs in some companies
that that millennial customers
particularly want some kind of
commitment from the company that they're
buying from is that playing into this
too they want to know that the brand
that they're buying from understands
them understand what they think of the
world and relates to them as a consumer
I do think that that's playing a part in
this so as the part is the sort of
political stand driven actually by
market research I mean this is just
about targeting customers is it not I
think it's just about being in the
zeitgeist you know they they want to do
a lot to be talked about they want to be
in conversations that are you know
filled with fervor and people are
talking about they want to be in there
so I think if you look at Pepsi's
commercial but that was he bad talking
about was it was and it is what have you
talking about like it was tone-deaf you
know they didn't they wanted to be
talked about as being part of the
conversation about protests and about
you know understanding this type of
topic it obviously completely missed the
market was an incredibly tone-deaf but
that's what they were aiming for right
so how has this affected the content and
the placement of advertising yeah I
think that's just
important it's not just the creative
anymore it's where ads are running we
see with Breitbart all of the
advertisers that have pulled out from
there because of all of the noise on
social media and you know consumers
saying we don't want to see your ads on
places that are not trustworthy we see
with Google and YouTube how edge or
appearing in some you know terrorist
back content many advertisers pulled off
of youtube and then you see with Bill
O'Reilly and his show how advertisers
are reacting more than 50 advertisers
pulling out of the show in response to
the allegations made against him so I
think it's really important right now
that it's not just about creative but
also where you're running your ads we
saw this week how social media can
absolutely damage brand the United
Airlines video that went viral exchanged
hundreds of millions of times around the
world in terms of social media and viral
video do brands have the infrastructure
do they have people on staff that
understand social media in the way that
they need to in the 21st century they
say they do they definitely have you
know you see many brands have war rooms
and have people who are just in charge
of their social media but a lot of times
you know it's quick thinking a lot of
quick reaction that's needed I think
skittles was probably one of the best
ones to do a reaction when when Donald
Trump you know make comments about
refugees and comparing them to see it I
think that they did the right thing
because they came out and they said you
know refugees or people's skittles or
candy that's it we're not making any
other statement on this because we don't
want to appear as though we're using
this as a marketing opportunity you
think that's what's important to
remember this is real life situations
you know these are not marketing
opportunities and you think when brands
use them as such that's when they really
got into trouble alright Jeanine Poggi
thanks very much for being with us this
morning